hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular game where Bobby Fischer
employs the Evans Gambit against Ruben
fine in 1963. there we have it the Evans
Gambit a Reuben accepts at Bishop to A5
and here we go for a very known line D
captures on C3 Queen to B3 goes after F7
Queen t7 and now Knight captures in C3
and here Ruben misses it with Knight to
F6 he allows Knight to D5 characters
captures attacks the Knight Knights the
E5 captures captures and Bishop to B2 we
have Queen to G5 and now H4 deflects the
queen from the defense of the G7 Pawn
characters captures and now Rook to G8
attacks the bishop Rook after E1 check
King 38 and now Queen to G3 and here
Ruben resigns as uh he either loses the
queen or he takes Fisher's Queen and
then Bishop to F6 is just an Unstoppable
Checkmate so there we have it the Evans
Gambit Fisher play that you can play it
you can win mini games I hope you enjoy